if you've ever eaten spaetzle chances
are this is probably how they were
served mixed with different types of
cheese and topped with glazed onions
it's the most popular way to eat this
treat but by no means the only one
spaetzle with lentils is another
favorite long ago if is a meal eaten by
the poor but now Swabian noodles are
also served as a side dish with meat the
pronunciation can be a challenge though
sputter sputter sputter sabbatic we make
them on the board come on bro you have
to have the right flour respect the
flour it's a bit more coarse asta man
and my mother always really enjoyed
making them zag Danica cooked the
ingredients are simple flour eggs salt
and water are mixed in a bowl
but preparation is a bit of a chore the
dough has to be beaten thoroughly to get
all the air bubbles out
there are different ways to cook them up
you can grate them for example but then
the dough has to be very firm or you can
put the mix through a press
that's quickest
the most traditional way is to use a
knife to scrape the soft dough from
aboard into boiling water and especially
for Salt Lake's Lavetta pressed always
thicker and firmer if they're scraped by
hand the more tender grated ones are
best for cheese Schmidt's leg they're
already creamy aromatic and a bit cheesy
to taste que se French make spaetzle
were first mentioned in print at the
beginning of the 18th century the dish
is said to have originated in southern
Germany and a persuade via in 2013 a
museum dedicated dish Metzler opened in
batbot a a small town south of stuttgart
it looks back on at least two centuries
of this Hulan airy specialty the
exhibits are made up of cooking utensils
old cookbooks and even children's toys
including this dollhouse from 1870
the museum's director Heidi Hoover has
also found rare cookbooks dating back to
1809 including one of the first recipes
with quantities what's the tag of the
Millea but when you make livid spaetzle
today and get the liver from the butcher
it's already prepared and here it says
you skin scrape and chop 375 grams of
calf's liver pipes level that's quite a
difference hurts inside so you think
that I don't think I'd ever make liver
spaetzle if I had to do all that myself
historian Miguel baoqiang has written a
book about 16th century eating habits
spaetzle had not yet appeared although
something similar was first created in
the 17th century by chopping dumplings
into little bits
starting in the 19th century the dough
was put through Mills grates and presses
to simplify preparation ideas about the
name origins very das spaetzle if you
take the word spaetzle and leave off the
Swabian diminutive ending la you could
have spaetzle which in Italian means
something like string or lace that's how
it came into Swabian when so we have
this that is maybe she could call me
most families in the region have their
very own special recipe and the dish is
also on the menu at nearly every
restaurant
this anak me and it reminds me of my
childhood and simply tastes superb and
for classic spaetzle a regional classic
that's become a favorite food across
Germany
you